mein name ist mathias mich ne ski und
ich war 13 jahre lang peter steiger beim
bau des gotthard basistunnels also der
wetter steiger ist verantwortlich für
die belüftung im tunnel und für die
kühlung mit absteiger das kommt aus dem
bergbau es ist ein traditioneller
berufseinsteiger ist eine bergmännische
aufsichtsperson und der wetter steiger
wetter wird im bergbau die luft genannt
und deswegen heißt das dann eben eine
belüftungs technische aufsichtsperson
eben ein peter steiger
mein vater war selbst auf einem berg
beschäftigt in einem aufsichts position
und hat zu mir natürlich immer wieder
gesagt nein junge ist nicht auf eine so
genannte c jugend ins bergwerk du
solltest mal besser haben als sich die
gäste deutschen sagen ja habe ich auch
gemacht ich habe damals schlosser
gelernt und leider war es dann so dass
die deutsche bahn in einer krise war
mein nächster traumwelt werk und ich hab
doch praktisch auf einem bergweg danach
angefangen
seit über 30 jahren arbeite ich im
dunkeln im tunnel dem werk going überall
wo es eigentlich nur löcher gibt sondern
nicht habe ich eigentlich dabei noch nie
vermisst als maulwurf und ich finde
eigentlich pudong eine tätigkeit als
wetter steiger weil einige auf sich
gezogen
wir hatten so genannte frischluft
ventilatoren zugriff ventilatoren die
luft durch große schläuche zu den
einzelnen arbeitsstellen geblasen haben
und dann hatten wir noch einmal
ventilatoren die oben im schacht 2
installiert waren die haben einen
unterdruck erzeugt im tunnel also haben
wir den tunnel gesaugt und haben somit
die luft die neben den lippen vorbei
geströmt es wieder zurück aufgenommen
und haben die aus dem tunnel gymnasien
dadurch dass wir sprengt betrieb hatten
musste der tunnel auch jedes mal nach
einer spritze getestet werden ob die
atemluft wiedergegeben ist ob die
sprengsätze abgeleitet wurden ob man
wieder vernünftig arbeiten kann
denn sprechblase sind die brose gase
sind sehr gefährlich für lungen- und
hatten können erkrankungen können risse
auftreten also sehr schwer hohen still
um die luft in dem tunnel zu testen gibt
es verschiedene möglichkeiten eine davon
ist zum beispiel die nebelmaschine ganz
normale nebelmaschine wie man sie für
jede bühne fürs theater braucht ist doch
vollkommen ausreichend sie erzeugt
traurig kann anhand von dem rauch sehen
wie die strömung läuft und es eigentlich
schon ein sehr gutes mittel zum beispiel
auch um bei crash legen die türen auf
dichtigkeit zu testen denn ich darf
unter wesentlich luft verlieren
die eröffnung ist natürlich ein
zweischneidiges schwert für mich einmal
ist es natürlich himmelhoch jauchzt juli
wird eröffnet endlich geht's los
wir haben eine big party ein staatsakt
eine ganze woche lang kriterien in uri
gefeiert der tunnel wird eröffnet aber
das andere ist daneben auch das geht
eine sehr schöne zeit zu ende
den bau des tunnels und hat sehr viele
erfahrungen sammeln wenn man hat viele
freunde gefunden man hat einen ganz
anderen lebenswelt lebensabschnitt
mitgemacht hier in der schweiz gegenüber
deutschland und ich werde mir meine frau
der schweiz träumerei mond jungen
schweiz gucken dass es ein zukunfts
mäßig egal wie von der spd in tunnel
weiter
oder eben bei einem neuen projekt
ich weiß es noch nicht viel wenn alle
türen sind offen